rêvez-vous d'avoir une voiture
pas spécialement tu as passé plusieurs
pourquoi
ces pratiques je pense m'en acheter une
pour les vacances pour jeunes si je m'en
moque évidemment votre père vous
l'offrir à je suppose non je ne veux la
paix prépare mon travail personnel en
quelque sorte que vous faites
je travaillerai pour nous la commune
c'est pas par exemple à l'american
express ou aux rideaux djs s'offrir une
voiture oui j'aimerais une voiture mais
pour mme et on a un groupe acheté une
vieille voiture un groupe et puis faire
des balades partir en vacances à quel
âge pensez vous être capable de produire
une voiture à wonder 18 19 ans c'est
encore assez chemin pensez vous que
l'âge de 18 ans pas bien chasser pour la
délivrance du permis de conduire oh oui
certainement passé espère même même 18
ans est dangereux de confier une voiture
j'ai peut-être un peu trop jeune moi je
me rends quand même content je vais
bientôt avoir dit citant microsoft seul
ce canevas lui inquiet fois capable
devrait le conduire que je serais
peut-être un danger public d'en face
c'est pour ça que je devais faire un
instrument plutôt lent c'est trop jaune
parce que à 18 ans je pense que on a
trop tendance à vouloir faire de la
vitesse
quelle est la qualité primordiale pour
une voiture pratique luxueuse rapide
pratique
pourquoi pratique pour sciences sincères
pour son travail pour moi
rapide et confortable pratique je pense
rapide pour un jeune
puis pratiqué jusque 4 et maintenant
rendant visite aux jeunes souveraine et
de chez renault qui le fabriquent ces
objets merveilleux
est-ce que vous rêvez d'avoir une
voiture ça oui oui pourquoi
moi j'aime la voiture ah oui beaucoup
pourquoi c'est beaucoup plus pratique
comme moyen de locomotion puis c'est
plus rapide
non pas tellement pourquoi le risque oui
comme tout le monde et une voiture est
ce que c'est pour vous un objet utile ou
un objet de luxe de luxe pourquoi parce
que ya beaucoup d'ouvriers qui ne se la
payer et circule en voiture est mieux
que prendre le métro
oui pourquoi un certain confort qu'on ne
trouve pas dans le métro
oui ça fait cinq ans que je prends le
métro est sûr que j'en ai c'est bien
pensez vous que 18 ans voilà soit un âge
bien choisi pour l'attribution du permis
de conduire font preuve ue à quel âge
souhaiteriez-vous comme dans tout la
tribu 17 ans alors vous vous tenteriez
votre permis tout de suite ça dépend
encore des gens c'est ça les vents des
personnes il y en a certains à 18 ans
qui conduisent prudemment alors que
d'autres même à 20 ou 21 ans ont encore
un peu foufou wallon pensez vous que 18
ans soit un âge bien choisi pour
l'attribution des permis de conduire non
pourquoi on est trop jeune pour conduire
une voiture au style quel âge vous avez
beau à 10 88
oui mais il faut le souligner un peu
plus sérieux de l'examen c'est à dire
c'est dire que
par exemple point de vue médical vu tout
ça pour explique plus sérieux
ce soit ou un peu la fumisterie comme
l'heure actuelle 16 ans 17 ans à
pourquoi vous pensez qu'à saison 10 au
17 ans on puisse conduire une voiture je
vais vous je pense oui sans danger son
nom j'étais là je vous avais pas joué
sur 17 ans et laquelle il est primordial
pour une voiture pratique luxueuses ou
rapide luxueuse rapide je mettrais
plutôt luxueux se défont certain goût
pour certains ce sont la rapidité
à quel âge pensez vous qu'un jeune
ouvrier et doit posséder une voiture en
revenant du service militaire
pourquoi justement retenant les services
militaires bal commencera déjà à gagner
sa vie et plus il peut se marier en
revenant du service militaire parce que
beaucoup de jeunes qui se marie en
revenant et ça va avec la famille ça va
avec la famille en vérité voilà une
sagesse qui méritent des lauriers nous
serions nous tromper une fois pour
toutes selon les rapports de
l'automobile avec la jeunesse
[Musique]